gone is doing like what my dad does when
now it's more oh [__] oh I'm [__] by
the end of this podcast this wine is
going to be up to the brim
sorry man I'm [__] [__] it was a cool
memory for me drinking with your dad and
having the yeah
[Music]
birdie I've got I forgot what the
cocktail yeah cockatiel I was just
having this the coffee was chilled on my
shoulder for like two hours
he loved you I was like yes let's drink
wine there's like a pet shop like near
where we live that we have to walk past
uh every time we like we could go out in
the window and like they have this whole
section of like birds I'm like I keep
walking past please join the bird
Brigade birds are the [__] best those
are good and the more I go on the more I
realize how gooded they are yeah you
know everyone has a dog and a cat but
you know you don't have to take a bird
out for a walk they have a ton of
Personality yeah they do that's great
question yeah have you changed being a
dog or a cat person over time uh yeah
because I after I found it because he's
like yeah All-Star found out I was
allergic to cats I became a dog person
yeah but you still like cats I still
love cats right but that's good there is
the phys yeah it's really I've
flip-flopped between being well so what
are you now I think I'm a dog person
right now dog person I think it matches
my energy of where I'm at in life yeah I
think for a good five years he's just
been hanging out with didus a lot why
because he has like Labrador energy he
does he does he is a labrador dude he's
a he's a baby Labrador okay like I
always flip-flop between the two because
I like honestly perfect life I actually
won both I want a dog and a cat and a
bird
they can't live in harmony unless they
can depends on the breed they'll be up
to Shenanigans
one of them is dying yeah like I I don't
know I I just the more I end up I feel
like the happier I am the more I want a
dog yeah to match my level of
satisfaction in life and the cat is that
when I'm feeling down I'm like just
brood with me just sitting just just
chill just just sit in the corner while
I watch TV wait did you own any pets
growing up no never really no I don't
know why I think because we were always
surrounded by pets like all our friends
had pets you know because in Wales it's
so common to have a dog it's so easy to
have but also you you're like what a
family of like what three other brothers
yeah and I think we always ask for pets
but our mom was like are you gonna take
care of it because if you don't take
care of it no haven't it did you have
pascara I did not have any pets I had a
goldfish I wanted a fair you might as
well
I think I like must have like inherited
something from my dad
because my dad told me once that my
dad's like always been like an Auntie
like kind of like animal pet person and
I thought he just [__] hated animals
the longest time in my life uh and then
like I remember like having a
conversation with them one day about
like how he took care of a cat and like
you know yeah when the cat passed away
he was just like I would never love an
animal again you know that's like I I I
think that personally yeah I'm like yeah
I get it you lost a member of your
family and then you were like no I am
not ready for another one yeah and
that's I think that's like the
philosophy I would have because I don't
know if I've told this man like this uh
not the birds uh yeah I don't I didn't
technically have pets growing up but I
had like
dot like family dogs in like Thailand uh
like around the neighborhood yeah yeah
like no like we uh so like my Thai home
we have like a [__] massive family
home a bunch of dogs there when I was
like [__] four years old we like
adopted some puppies uh they let me know
them and uh the names were Pepsi and
cola wow
and I will never forget Pepsi Cola uh
for the rest of my life and like every
time I'd come back to Thailand because I
come back to Thailand every year they'd
always remember me even if it's been
like a little bit longer since I've seen
them
um and basically we grew up at the same
time because I heard them when I was a
kid and I saw them grow up they were
good boys and then they were gone and
I'm like for the longest time I'm like I
don't even know that I I don't want
another pet I I totally feel that man
yeah I think so far I have lost
in my life
yeah sure excuses because again like my
my family [__] especially my parents
[__] love animals so like at every
moment in my life there was at least
some kind of pet or animal yeah just
existing in my house like growing up and
yeah I mean it [__] sucks like
obviously losing a a pet that you've had
even if it's for a short amount of time
like you know
um it [__] sucks if it does feel like
a family death but like
I don't know it's uh it's always
rewarding to be able to like get to that
point where the you can feel that that
severely about it yeah exactly where you
can like you can be with this animal
yeah its entire lifetime and then for
you to be there when it passes like
that's a really special moment and like
it doesn't get any easier obviously but
like just give it a good life you get
yeah just the satisfaction of like this
animal probably thinking to itself like
thank you for giving me a good life like
it was fun I know just thinking about
this man it reminds me of all the pets I
had and it's [__] in net like the few
times I ever saw my dad cry was when our
pets died and I was like that [__]
hit me hard and like obviously the pet
dying was one thing but then seeing my
[__] parents cry like that [__] that
[__] broke my heart as a kid we need a
trash chased dog
if one of us had a dog no and we just
like hey do you mind if Steve comes to
the office today you'll be like okay
question okay question what's your dream
pet right now flip-flopping what's your
dream pet if you had to pick one pet to
have right now
what would it be I wish you had the
shiba inu with the energy of a golden
retriever y probably uh I'll probably
exist I don't know they're like Shivers
can be quite energetic if they're young
but I want the love of a golden
retriever well then you best get a
golden retriever they're huge for Japan
oh for Japan yeah what would you get I'm
gonna get a dog I'm gonna get one I
think I want a parakeet right now
parakeet I know I'm in like the bird
phase yeah
the dudes are the type of dudes who'd
make ancient Scrolls like 500 years ago
um that's more so with me because I want
to now you want an owl yeah you'll never
see it it's nocturnal no no no no it's
like if if it's if it's a raised like
hand raised then like they're more so
like fitted to like staying up a little
bit later than the usual sleep schedule
they're like the they're like the day to
sleep schedule the vowels all right like
that it's like pretty much the opposite
like so yeah no because like Japan is
one of the few countries in the world
where you can own a pet owl without any
necessary um documentation or like
licenses and Japan's really weird like
that ferrets are another one that you
can own here chinchillas you can only
you can own parrots in most countries
but with a license
I don't think so yeah mostly my friends
own ferrets really yeah or chinchillas I
know for a fact you can only own in
Japan I mean legally and chinchilla is a
[__] adorable as well Japan has a
really weird
outlook on animals like the reason I
said like no to like a trash cheese dog
is just because like to me a dog is like
a baby well I don't know what I mean by
trash taste dog is yeah I have the dog
I'm having the dog but would you if I
had a dog would you object to the dog
turning up every week can we just chill
with the dog no of course that'd be hype
as [__] what would you name your dog
oh man I don't know I
part of me wanted to do it like it's
like a monarch name just to kind of get
back at them just Charles
my favorite is when people give their
pets really human names or give it like
some kind of uh I don't know dude I I
thought I I really wanted to get a dog
and just yeah his full name would be ask
lad but he would be lad live or lad but
he but his ass
he's the goat he's the ghost I I had a
friend who had a dog uh it was like a
miniature schnauzer or something come
here boy I had a conversation with
Sydney we were talking about like you
know what if we had a boy what would you
name it and Cindy was like oh I have
some names I like Kirito
and she was like oh yeah I really like
the name I actually really like the name
Johan or Griffith oh my father and I was
just like Sydney what the two evilest
[__] yeah what are you trying
to like what are you like trying to
cultivate here Sydney so I really like
the name Hitler
is a pretty cool name
Johan you guys are not a German enough
as a couple
can you imagine in like 10 years time uh
this is my son Johan manitartha
you would like the whitish name in
existence so I was like oh this is
Malcolm Jones
like that's hard I like I what imagine
having a kid and having to name them
like that's so much mean
never owned a pet of course I'm of
course I'm drunk yes I have never owned
whatever I mean I got [__] Pepsi Cola
that's probably my favorite drink when I
was [__] four years old yeah that's
not that bad when I was born we had
little guy in Pocky listen so it's not
it's not that much different it doesn't
matter because Joey's dad didn't even
use his real name half the time yeah
yeah I mean I that just seems like
obviously you know I'll get to that
bridge when I come to it uh but like
maybe your kid that's like so much
pressure right because wow yeah just
pick an easy name
what are you gonna call your son yeah
I'll figure it out I'd be like Steve or
something bro No One's Gonna Give A [__]
uh Beyond yeah
by the way congratulations to Felix for
being a [__] Dad yeah congratulations
hell yeah why are we clapping he
literally ensured him
well done